[Applaus]
[Musik]
mai 2018 legte der damalige präsident
der vereinigten staaten von amerika
donnerstag das atom abkommen mit den
iran verhängt erneut
wirtschaftssanktionen gegen das regime
die übrigens in katar starten des
abkommens und die europäische union
selbst wollten es am leben erhalten aber
in diesem punkt liegt die klamm
kastration hat und ihre entscheidung
ließ keinen handlungsspielraum zu es war
ein wenn über nacht haben die sanktionen
den mullahs jene angenehmen vorteile die
sie durch den nuklear packt erhalten
hatten
vr der exporte und direktinvestitionen
den schönen warmen geldregen aus dem
ausland der iran ging daraufhin wieder
zum angriff über und brach mehrere
seiner versprechen auch gegenüber den
anderen vertragspartnern offen zugeben
wollten sie dies nicht aber zum glück
gibt es ein land auf der welt das die
nuklearen machenschaften des islamischen
gottesstaates minutiös beobachtet und
ihr wisst wahrscheinlich schon alle
davon welchem land die rede ist genau
von israel in der tat stellt dank der
versöhnung zwischen israel und den
arabischen rechten heute der iran
die einzige wirkliche bedrohung der
existenz israels dar vor allem natürlich
sein atomwaffenprogramm
könnte der iran also wirklich die
atombomben dickel welche rolle spielt
dabei die neue beiden investitionen und
die vielleicht wichtigste frage von
allem was um alles in der welt
unternimmt israel dagegen heute werden
wir hier auf visual politik all diese
fragen beantworten höher geht es also
gut zu
[Musik]
ein geheimer krieg wenn es eine sache
gibt es über die sich die israelische
regierung im klaren ist dass es immer
besser ist den feind zuvor zu kommen
bevor diese ein selbst angreift vor
allem wenn es um die eigene nackte
existenz geht die haupt diese israels in
puncto sicherheit lautet deswegen sich
bedrohungen immer direkt gegenüber zu
stellen
diese idee namen vor knapp 40 jahren
gestalt an er ist der damalige
premierminister nach dem begehen
beschloss dem irakischen atomreaktor
osirak anzugreifen
damit nahm die sogenannte wiking doktrin
ihren anfang
gefordert ist
die provisorische sperre
mit der bg doktrin verbietet israel der
welt dass es sich das recht vorbehält
einen präventivschlag gegen jeden fall
zu führen der versucht
massenvernichtungswaffen zu entwickeln
zum beispiel hat die operation opera der
angriff auf den irak 1981 das
atomwaffenprogramm von salons sie
erheblich verzögert doch dies war kein
einzelfall ein weiteres exempel
statuierte israel 2007 mit der operation
obst daten als es einem im bau
befindlichen atomreaktor in syrien
bombardierte um das al assad regime
daran zu hindern bei der herstellung von
plutonium voranzukommen aber lasst uns
für einen moment innehalten und unser
augenmerk wieder auf den iran richten
[Musik]
das iranische atomprogramm seit jeher
von den wichtigsten westlichen mächten
abgelehnt trotz der beteuerungen dass es
friedlichen zwecken diene
ausschliesslich zivile energieerzeugung
natürlich hat der westen diese
behauptung schon immer in frage gestellt
nicht zuletzt wegen des betriebs 4000
iranisches uran zentrifugen zur
anreicherung waffenfähigen materials
als reaktion darauf bestrafen die usa
und die eu den iran seit jahren mit
wirtschaftssanktionen die den iran von
der fortführung seines
atomwaffenprogramms abhalten sollen aber
wir haben ja bereits erwähnt dass es die
einzige existenzielle bedrohung für
israel heute genau der iran der
ajatollahs ist und es ist klar dass
diese niemals ruhe geben werden denn sie
sind geradezu besessen von der
zerstörung israels immer wieder und
oberster führer ajatollah khamenei
direkte anspielung an den massenmord der
nazis zur endlösung auf zur vollkommenen
auslöschung israels mit allen zur
verfügung stehenden mitteln auch mit
atombomben sobald der iran über diese
verfügen sollte
deswegen hat sich der hebräische staaten
ist eine beginnt aktien dazu entschieden
atomprogramm durch kann die separation
von vornherein zu verhindern eine
prominente rolle kommt dabei natürlich
seinen legendären geheimdienst muss dazu
über welche art mission reden wir also
nun über klassische spionage aber auch
über moderneren boden wie die operation
olympic games den ersten großen
cyberangriff der geschichte
bereits zu beginn dieses jahrhunderts
benutze den iran zu entriegeln die auf
einem von einer niederländischen firma
gestohlen design basierten aus diesem
grund kontaktierten der moz und die cia
den niederländischen geheimdienst um
über einen maulwurf die iranische
atomanlage in natans mit dem stück cnet
virus zu infizieren
dabei handelt es sich um einfache
israelischen und amerikanischen
geheimnis programmieren entwickelt des
computervirus welches die steuer
software von siemens steueranlagen an
welche auch die zentrifugen in natans
angebunden sind so modifiziert dass sie
unbemerkt zu schnell rotieren und
dadurch beschädigt wurde das stück
streams ist unglaublich clever
programmiert und wurde es im juni 2010
entdeckt nachdem es bereits über 1000
zentrifugen zerstört hatte 20 prozent
kapazität des dortigen
urananreicherungsprogramms tja eine
technische meisterleistung
am erstaunlichsten ist aber vielleicht
dass der mossad immer wieder seine
fähigkeit demonstriert direkt auf
iranischen territorium zu operieren
quasi erst kürzlich im jahr 2018 gelangt
ist israelischen spionen die iraner eine
große menge geheimer dokumente zu
stibitzen um dann genüsslich aller welt
zu beweisen dass das iranische
atomprogramm noch immer quicklebendig
ist ganz anders als die mullahs ist
behaupten dies war für trump der letzte
tropfen der das iranische lügen fast zum
überlaufen brachte er kündigte den
nuklear die auf sollten sich doch die eu
und alle anderen von den äußerungen
mussas an der nase herum zu lassen der
israelische premierminister benjamin
netanjahu präsentierte die unterlagen
damals sogar höchstpersönlich im
fernsehen und was du dir den namen
gemerkt die uns allen ein bleiben wollte
nein keine angst so wichtig ist aber
nicht mehr
denn wer ihn sich damals sehr gut
gemerkt hat weil er muss
vox sind friseure irans top
atomwissenschaftler wird in der nähe von
teheran ermordet
tja kernforscher in iran zu sein ist ein
riskanter beruf geworden
bereits fünf iranische wissenschaftler
wurden in den letzten jahren mit wie die
rdx aber damit kein falscher eindruck
gesteht wir reden hier nicht von
irgendwelchen unschuldslämmer fachlich
sadek war der vordenker des art project
wir sprechen von einer person die sich
seit jahrzehnten der geheimen
erforschung von atomwaffen gewidmet hat
denn auch nachdem die iranische führung
der nuklear deal mit den usa und der eu
beschlossen und hoch und heilig
geschworen hat die atomwaffenprogramm zu
stoppen vorstellig sah der in aller
heimlichkeit munter weiter an der
entwicklung der atombombe
[Musik]
der mutter behauptet das ganze 70
prozent der arbeiten haben am projekt
einfach im rahmen einer neuen
geheimorganisation vorgeführt wurden
und ja vielleicht gerade verlust
bundestag mehr symbolischen effektiv da
ist dutzende von wissenschaftlern gibt
die als team hinter dem projekt arbeiten
aber es war ein klares signal israels
wie entschlossen es ist die umsetzung
dieses programms zu verhindern
so wurde das iranische atomprogramm auch
im vergangenen jahr durch weitere cyber
anderes sabotageakte kompromittiert
anlagen in denen ohne erklärung alle
möglichen arten von problemen auftragen
brände explosionen stromausfälle sehr
viele zufälle zu viele
sie alle trugen zusammen dazu bei den
gesamt fortschritt von irans
atomprogramm zu verlangsamen
wer ist also für diese vorfälle
verantwortlich nun israel hat auf diese
frage immer die sogenannte normale
antwort wir können unsere beteiligung
weder bestätigen noch dementieren für
eine person gibt es dennoch keinerlei
zweifel
mohammed erwartet sachlich irans
aussenminister terroristen haben heute
einen bedeutenden iranischen
wissenschaftler ermordet diese feigheit
mit ernstzunehmenden hinweisen auf eine
israelische beteiligung zeigt die
verzweifelte kriegstreiberei der täter
tja der mann hat allen grund sich
aufzuregen denn die mission des mossad
im iran lassen selbst james bond wie ein
pfadfinder aussehen glaubt ihr dass ich
übertreibe
dann hört gut zu den jetzt erkläre ich
euch warum dieses extreme maß an
professionalität gerade jetzt für die
israelis von existenzieller dort wo
gestern
[Musik]
zurück in die zukunft
im monat april wird im iran der
nationale tag der nukleartechnologie
gefeiert viele von euch stellen sich
wahrscheinlich vor das dann dass
ayatollah regime als eine nacht zur
schau stelle um seine feinde ehrfurcht
erstarren zu lassen und ja
selbstverständlich hat er an diesem
feiertag nicht ungenutzt verstreichen
lassen ohne ein paar hübsche propaganda
videos zu drehen also weißt du
wenigstens warum israel in euro vision
song contest viermal gewonnen hat und er
noch nicht mal teilnehmen darf aber
scherz beiseite
israel muss handeln denn der gottesstaat
nutzt seine zentrifugen nicht nur als
hippe locations für seine musikvideos
seit dem ausstieg der usa aus dem
nuklear pakt ist der iran noch weiter
über die darin gesetzten limit
hinausgegangen
zum beispiel was die maximal erlaubten
bestände an und schwerem wasser und uran
angeht tatsächlich stellte die iga die
internationale atomenergie behörde im
februar 2021 fest dass ihre angst vor
reden angereicherten uran 14 mal größer
waren als das festgelegte limit außerdem
ist der iran air und fortschrittliche
rezession als erlaubt eine fast
logischerweise dazu dient die
anreicherung von uran zu beschleunigt
natürlich vorkommendes uran besteht aus
zwei verschiedenen isotopen so 39,3
prozent aus uran mit der masse zahl 238
was euch uninteressant ist zu 0,7
prozent besteht aber aus dem uran 235
und dessen kämen können durch thermische
elektronen gespalten werden das heißt es
ermöglicht eine selbst erhaltendes
kernspaltung kettenreaktion in gang zu
setzen
diese erzeugt dann entweder kontrolliert
energie in einem reaktor oder sie
explodiert unkontrolliert in einem
atombombe sprengkopf der unterschied
zwischen kraftwerks tauglichen und
atomwaffen uran macht nun der
prozentuale anteil eben jenes uran-235
isotops am gesamt uhr an dem ich aus ab
3 prozent trend ist gut in einem
kernreaktor
deswegen lag das im atom abkommen mit
den iran fest mit 3,67 prozent
doch der iran zentrifugiert sein uran
auch darüber hinaus unsere weiter
hinweise grub er die u 235 konzentration
über dem erlaubten grenzwert von 3,67
prozent
zuerst stieg sie auf viereinhalb prozent
dann auf 20 prozent und ja es ist noch
immer weit von 90 prozent entfernt bei
denen uran waffenfähig werden aber
moment mal denn im april stellten dann
alle alarmglocken
der iran beginnt mit der anreicherung
von uran auf 60 prozent dem höchsten
stand aller zeiten warum zum teufel
braucht der iran 60 prozent
angereichertes uran
wenn er vor gibt es nur in kernreaktoren
zu nutzen für die ja 3,5 prozent
vollkommen ausreichen würden nun so
langsam gehen den mullahs die ausreden
aus und so haben sie tatsächlich
angedeutet dass der iran
doch an einer neuen uran fabrik bauen
könnte die ihnen mit jene
materialversorgung würde dass er zur
herstellung einer atombombe benötigt
natürlich eine voll funktionsfähige
atombombe zu bauen ist eine große
herausforderung so mancher bastler hatte
ich daran ist eine modelleisenbahn im
keller und die zähne ausgebissen aber in
jedem fall scheint jetzt allen klar zu
sein dass der iran heute näher dran ist
als je zuvor über voll funktionsfähige
kernwaffen zu verfügen tatsächlich
schätzen einige experten dass der iran
in der lage wäre bereits in neun monaten
mit atomwaffentests zu beginnen eine
einfache atomwaffen innerhalb eines
jahres zu bauen und einen vollwertigen
atomsprengkopf auf einer ballistischen
rakete in nur zwei jahren anbringen zu
können falls ist so keine weitere
störungen kommen sollte und trotz all
dem gibt es immer noch ein paar
unverbesserliche die allen ernstes
glauben es bliebe noch genügend zeit
obamas nuclear abkommen aus dem jahr
2015 noch irgendwie zu retten und
darunter befindet sich leider auch der
aktuelle bewohner des weißen hauses
[Musik]
präsident biden ist fest entschlossen
dass die usa zum iran atomar abkommen
zurückkehren sollten obwohl es zu diesem
zeitpunkt nicht klar ist dass diese in
irgendeiner weise wirkung zeigen und die
vorbereitungen des nuklearen holocaust
stoppen würde aber erinnern wir uns an
einst als beide noch obamas
vizepräsident war hat er wirklich alles
getan um das atom abkommen im
us-kongress durchzuboxen
dieser war nämlich ganz und gar nicht
von dessen wirksamkeit überzeugt und
blockierte ist sehr lang so groß wäre
also beides gesichtsverlust würde er nun
vom atom abkommen drücken und damit
eingestehen dass er auch damals auf dem
holzweg war liebe hält er weiter an der
illusion das fest diesmal soll alles
anders oder iran würde sich schon dazu
bringen lassen die festgelegten
grenzwerte wieder einzuhalten
jetzt wo sie bei über 60 prozent das
problem ist aber dass teheran genau weiß
das ist auf diplomatischer ebene alle
trümpfe in der hand hält auf der einen
seite forderte iran dass die usa alle
von kramp verhängten
wirtschaftssanktionen aufheben oder auf
der anderen seite weiß er wie er druck
auf verhandlungen ausüben kann sie immer
folgendes an iran verknüpft zugang für
un atominspekteure mit fortschritt bei
gesprächen in den letzten monaten hat
der iran den un inspekteuren zugang zu
seinen atomanlagen immer mehr erschwert
nun werden wir sogar zeuge dessen dass
teheran die inspektionen mit einem
entgegenkommen bei dieser handlung sagt
dieter lassen sollten jedoch aufpassen
dass sich die schlinge um beides heißt
nicht zu sehr zu ziehen
denn sowohl israel als auch saudi
arabien während über ein scheitern der
verhandlungen hocherfreut wieso nun
schauen wir uns dazu doch mal an wie
sich die ereignisse dann wohnen
entwickeln würden
[Musik]
ein abkommen mit verbesserungspotenzial
also wer hat behauptet donald trump
hatte keinen plan als gedacht da hatte
er ganz sicher ob dieser plan gut oder
schlecht war ist eine andere sache aber
als eine entscheidung waren
zielgerichtet diesen fall wollte trump
durch die kündigung des abkommens das
eine tolle situation unter druck setzen
und das ist ihm gelungen
irans wirtschaft befindet sich in einer
tiefen rezession welche durch die
pandemie noch verschärft wird ihr könnt
euch darüber in einem anderen video
verlosen informieren während beiden also
glauben mag dass die usa niemals hätten
aufgehen dürfen ist er sich jetzt
sicherlich bewusst dass eine zweite
chance bekommen hat mit den iran über
einige aspekte des abkommens nur zu
verhandeln wenn auch nur um zeit zu
gewinnen
[Musik]
denn der nuklear pack drei lose enden
hinterlassen das wichtigste bezieht sich
auf seine klausel mit verfallsdatum zb
sollen die beschränkungen für die
entwicklung fortschrittlicher
technologie oder für irans importe und
exporte von raketen im jahr 2023
ablaufen und der großteil der
beschränkungen läuft bis 2030 sowieso
aus mit anderen worten das ganze
abkommen war von vornherein nichts also
ein spiel auf zeit ein weiteres problem
ist dass der deal das konventionelle
ballistische raketen programme gar nicht
betraft aber gerade raketen sind ein
schlüsselaspekt wenn die zeit gekommen
ist werden aus konventionellen ganz
schnell atomraketen wie du also siehst
würde es nicht mehr ausreichen das
abkommen allein wieder in kraft zu
setzen
es müssen das fast komplett neues
behandelt werden und das mit immer
längeren fristen und das ist genau der
grund warum man ihm in jerusalem und tel
aviv ganz und gar nicht traut
tatsächlich bereiten sich die
israelischen streitkräfte bereits auf
einen möglichen angriff vor sobald die
diplomatie mit ihrem latein am ende ist
wie glaubt nun sie ist ja ein
israelischer verteidigungsminister sagt
dass israel seine pläne iranische
atomanlagen anzugreifen aktualisiert
anfang des jahres forderte israels
generalstabschef eine finanzspritze von
fast einer milliarde dollar für die
streitkräfte
all dies mit einem ziel bis spätestens
2022 alles für einen konzertierten
angriff gegen das iranische atomprogramm
vorbereitet zu haben so dass israel
sofort losschlagen kann sollte es der
meinung sein dass der iran sich
gefährlich nahe an der fertigstellung
der atombombe befände natürlich ist dies
keineswegs eine einfache aufgabe
das atoll arrangieren weiß ganz genau
die ist ein atomprogramm schützen will
erstens indem es seine nuklearen an
im ganzen land verteilt zweitens indem
es diese anlagen in unterirdischen
bunkern einrichtet und schließlich in
dem es eine verteidigungsanlagen
aufrüstet wir sind zeugen eines brutalen
rüstungswettlaufs zwischen zwei ländern
und israel ist es ein wettlauf um leben
und tod
[Musik]
das israelische militär ist eines der
besten der welt der luftwaffe verfügt
über eine voll einsatzfähige ist es 35
gespart den modernsten flugzeug auf
diesem planeten und sein personal
verfügt über eine vielzahl von akne mit
überschall und repression der apple shop
ketten aus israelischer produktion
welche praktisch auf die ziele im iran
zugeschnitten sind doch die wohl größte
herausforderung von israel ist die große
entfernung zu seinen zielen in iran ein
problem das man lösen könnte wenn seine
streitkräfte direkten zugang zum
lufthansa saudi arabien bekämen den
anderen großen regionalen rivalen
und ja während israels deutliche
kommunikation nach außen schon eine
gewisse abschreckung darstellen kann
wäre es für die mullahs nicht vernünftig
zu denken dass die israelis ist dabei
bewenden ließen die vergangenheit hat
gezeigt dass die israel ist gemäss der
beginn doping immer handeln bevor es zu
spät ist bisher wahrscheinlich die
israelischen relativ kläger darauf die
herstellung von atomwaffen in iran zu
verhindern
sollte es den erlass aber dennoch
irgendwie gelingen um haaresbreite an
die eigene atombombe zu kommen dürfen
sie eines nicht vergessen die samson
option israels nuklearer abschreckung
szenario und sinne einer massiven
vergeltung denn israel verfügt
seinerseits ja schon lange über eine
atomarsenale von schätzungsweise bis zu
400 sprengköpfen welche per flugzeug u
boot kurz mittel oder per jericho
interkontinentalraketen ans ziel
gebracht und jeden feind als notwendig
sofort auslöschen würden aber denn auch
hier geld wir können das weder
bestätigen noch dementieren
deswegen fahren wir lieber euch glaubt
ihr dass israel erst mal angehört gegen
das iranische atomprogramm militärisch
loszuschlagen oder während die
diplomatischen bemühungen der beiden
administrationen doch noch irgendwie
erfolg haben und was würde passieren
wenn alle präventiven maßnahmen versagen
und es im nahen osten zum nuklearen
schlagabtausch kommen würde
teilt eure meinungen wie immer mit uns
und auch allen anderen ich hoffe dass
euch dieses video gefallen hat was er
hat geht uns mit einem leisen und
freunden vergesst nicht unseren kanal zu
abonnieren
machs gut shalom und bis bald
[Musik]